presented by movies anywhere your movies
together at last
download the movies anywhere app today
and bring your movie collection together
[Music]
before you experience Joaquin Phoenix's
twisted take on the Joker revisit the
shocking origins of live-action Batman
as a swinging cartoon crime buster
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb Batman the old TV show the movie
you love the dark Batman defining
performances of Keaton Bale and Affleck
now that Adam West take you back to
Batman's roots a bachelor who lives with
a teenage boy isn't exactly in peak
human condition and follows one ironclad
rule keep your hands off his girl show
me mascara or I'll wrap this place with
my dying breath if you've harmed that
girl kill you all
I'll rend you limb from lamp in an
interpretation that can only be
described as the love child of
Christopher Walken and Jeff Goldblum the
criminal catalyst in this entire affair
our old arch enemy Catwoman you already
knew that Robin sucked but did you know
he always sought watch Batman's original
sidepiece urban sidekick shill for the
cops support your police that's our
message condemned drunks to dead gosh
drinks you're a filthy thing isn't it
I'd rather be dead and unable to trust
my own eyes and suggest eugenics I'll
activate the computer link feed in the
various ethnic and national factors what
the way the world is and all don't you
think maybe we ought to try to improve
those factors kind of a little holy
master race master dick in fact the only
thing this Robin does well is cram a
holy bad pun into every sentence
[Music]
customization holy holy holy they aren't
even all puns it's like a verbal tic
holy almost this is actually sad
somebody help this boy holy jumble
menacing Gotham is a group of criminals
so crooked even the cameras are at an
angle
featuring Catwoman a devious diva whose
ratio of cats a woman is about 90 to 10
the penguin who can only speak in
nautical jargon because most of this
movie takes place at sea for some reason
the Riddler the perfect 60s villain
because you'd have to be on acid to
follow his logic what has yellow skin
and writes a ballpoint banana right one
weighs six ounces sits in a tree and is
very dangerous
a sparrow with a machine gun and the
Joker the first DC star to try and fail
to cover up a moustache together they'll
attempt to pull off the oldest caper in
the book turn world leaders into dust
with a dehydrating God meant for whiskey
production then ransom each country for
a billion dollars to be delivered via
carrier pigeon while they make their
getaway in a surplus military sub
disguised as a penguin just not all of
which culminates in a final sequence
they really makes you regret not going
to the bathroom before the third act
[Music]
come on come on Jesus shouldn't have
that big gulp Oh what is this taking so
long
why didn't I go cheering Padma stay with
Catwoman Holi depends Batman it's
happening too late
so revisit a simpler time when Batman
villains knew how to cavort bat fans
were happy to watch a good old-fashioned
punch mob
no one stressed the consequences of the
world's diplomats having their brains
and bodies scramble not even Batman our
job is finished let's go but
inconspicuously and the filmmakers had
the gall the nerve the audacity to not
take Batman super seriously
[Music]
no my edge it's speeding leap angst to
identify with story the masked swinger
Captain Underpants girl filled burgess
Meredith hail Cesare the government
wants to give you free money the help
awesome - gotta be funded a party and
brandy micro-tv bat-scanner Batmobile
position flush the bat-signal get the
fan charts watch and see step on the
back cast is super blinding back pellets
back gasps whiffle ball press bat speed
here take my bat radium unflattering and
venerable bat cameras polarized bat
filter man scanner tracking the stolen
Batmobile perfectly quickly be a
bat-cycle to the bat copter
[Applause]
Batman the groovy 1 billion dollars cash
from each country to be delivered to our
secret island by the Horde of train
carrier pigeons which I shall presently
provide so in $100 bills
1 billion us would wait twenty thousand
pounds given an average carrier pigeon
can lift 2.5 ounces it would take one
hundred and twenty eight thousand train
birds for the US alone that is a lot of
this episode was brought to you by
movies anywhere you choose where to
purchase your favorite movies we'll
bring them together in one place movies
anywhere download the app today I know
we're onto something I feel it in my
jellies mom but I love him in your movie
voice apoyando this